après deux mois d'absence et l'achat
d'un micro et elle commence à peine à
maîtriser
elle revient plus forte que jamais stop
pas besoin de faire une intro
grandiloquence pour montrer que tu as
enfin guéri thapan d'écriture je voulais
faire des jolis plans avec la cape et ou
enlève ta 4 maintenant c'est moi qui
porte le costume et raconte nous tes
trucs historique on a assez attendu
ok bonjour et bienvenue dans chroniques
de profs j'espère que vous êtes bien
réveillés parce qu'aujourd'hui on va
parler des pictes l'epeat lesdites les
pilotes et colégram
les pictes sont un peuple qui a vécu
entre le troisième et le neuvième siècle
et qui se trouvait à peu près là en
écosse en compagnie de tout un tas
d'autres peuples qui résistait encore et
toujours à l'envahisseur romain on les
connaît en grande partie grâce à la
description qu'en font les romains qui
sont confrontés à ce peuple lors de la
conquête de la bretagne et finissent par
construire un mur entre la partie
conquise et la partie nord du pays pour
s'assurer qu'il reste bien chez eux
il s'agit du mur d'hadrien qui est
complété par le mur d'antona un peu plus
haut vers 9 juin ce sont d'ailleurs les
romains qui donnent leur nom au pit
s'agit d'un dérivé de pythie qui
signifie un seul nom fait référence aux
peinture bleue dans l'épique semblait se
recouvrir et qui sont reprises chaque
fois qu'on voit des pictes apparaître au
cinéma
en réalité il est possible qu'il ne
s'agisse pas de simples peintures de
guerre mais de tatouage puisque un poète
roma par le dessin marqué au fer
malheureusement ne connaîtra
probablement jamais la vérité ni la
forme que prenait ses tatouages
avant l'arrivée des romains des pics de
samedi entre les prix tine et peut-être
avant ça les britanniques ce qui
pourrait avoir donné le nom latin de
brittany breton comme vous pouvez
constater il ya beaucoup d'hypothèses
mais peu d'affirmations par rapport à ce
peuple
on ignore par exemple quelle langue il
parlait et s'il s'agissait d'une langue
celtique ou s'il trouvait son origine
ailleurs du fait de leur mode de vie
différent de leur hostilité face à
l'arrivée des romains et des peintures
ou tatouages dont ils se parent et les
romains les ont rapidement catalogué
comme un peuple ou par bateau facile à
dire pour les romains à barbares c'était
quelqu'un qui n'était pas de culture
gréco-romaine
si c'est comme ça je suis par bach est
fier de lui d'ailleurs il semblerait que
l'épithète était le dernier peuple de
bretagne à se tatouer le corps ce qui
peut être vu comme un signe de fierté ou
de résistance quoi qu'il en soit les
représentations qu'on conserve 2 les
montres comme un peuple à ces
sanguinaires
comme sur cette image qui date du xviie
siècle ou encore celles ci on retrouve
souvent dans leurs présentations la
présence tard de tatouages qui ne
ressemble pas aussi donné sa roue
sur les pierres ou qui jouent pitt et
qu'ils sont donc probablement pas fidèle
et éventuellement des têtes de victimes
fraîchement découper parce qu'on n'a pas
encore assez insisté sur le fait qu'ils
étaient de gros barbare tout le monde
n'a pas l'air d'un barbare maintenant un
crâne dans sa main nous allons
maintenant voir que la réalité était un
peu différente
on sait déjà que les aider de bons
artistes ils nous ont laissé des pierres
représentants des formes géométriques ou
des symboles des animaux voire même des
croix le christianisme commençons à se
répandre dans les highlands alors que
les pistes existent encore on a
également retrouvé des bijoux comme
cette branche par exemple il semble
également qu'il est existait plusieurs
royaumes pitt belle le vénérable la
moine qui écrit au viiie siècle
d'histoire ecclésiastique du peuple
anglais raconte qu'il existe un peuple
pics du nord et du sud
il s'agissait probablement de sorte de
clan et on sait que les pics péter
matrilinéaire l'héritage de droit du
sang a été transmis par la mère et non
par le père les royaumes n'était donc
pas gouverner de père en fils mais
pouvait passer au fils au frère ou à
l'oncle seulement les fameux on a
retrouvé au bord du lot bouteilles en
écosse des vestiges d'un bâtiment où
vivaient plusieurs piques et qui nous a
permis d'en savoir un peu plus à leur
sujet en leur construisant ça a donné
ceci il s'agit d'un crâne sommes dans
lequel pouvait vivre une communauté de
20 à 40 personnes
on a également retrouvé dans le loch des
objets qui ne provenaient pas des
environs et qu'il a supposé que ces pics
commercer avec d'autres peuples
enfin d'après les romains il était aussi
de bons navigateurs toujours bon à
savoir ce qui rend les pictes un peu
légendaire ce n'est pas seulement le
manque d'informations dont on dispose
sur eux mais aussi le fait qu'au
neuvième siècle sur une petite dizaine
d'années et les pictes disparaissent
potable on ne retrouve pas de trace
d'art pitt après le neuvième siècle et
on ne peut que supposer les raisons de
leur disparition
tout au long de la période durant
laquelle vous
kitty n'était pas seul il coexister avec
tout un tas d'autres peuples notamment
les bretons dans le sud de l'angleterre
et les gars est venu d'irlande qui
vivaient dans l'ouest de l'ecosse les
relations entre les pictes est légal
n'était pas très bonne comme en atteste
la présence de forteresse tourner vers
les pitchs et les gays il avait une
culture totalement différente et des
gaels sont cristallisées dès le 6e
siècle
c'est d'ailleurs sur la terre que saint
colomban installe son premier monastère
en 563 dans l'espoir de christianiser
tout le reste de l'école il s'efforce
notamment de convertir des pictes et il
semble y parvenir puisque on observe une
évolution dans la représentation
c'est le cas notamment de cette pierre
qui date du viiie au 9e siècle et qui
complète un côté pitt et 1 faute et
chrétiens pile ou face
un pile des convertis cette diffusion du
christianisme a pu permettre à tous les
peuples des causes de s'aimer ou au
moins de se supporter dans le partage
d'une religion commune c'est pourquoi
l'équipe disparaissent en se fondant
dans les autres peuples existants pas si
vite il se passe d'autres choses
d'autres peuples entre en jeu et tentent
d'envahir le territoire
c'est le cas des angles qui domine déjà
le reste de la grande-bretagne et qui
décide de pousser au nord et également
des vikings dont je vous ai déjà parlé
dans ma précédente vidéo
c'est comme ça que les pictes
disparaissent en se faisant massacrer à
coups de casque à cornes fin mai en
professionnel dire n'importe quoi
on voit tes nouvelles il est probable
que des pictes et étaient massacrés
mais ces invasions force également les
peuples décosse a formé des alliances
plus resserré et c'est en 840 qu'entre
en jeu kenneth michael king qui devient
roi de tous les pitot et même des autres
peuples
peut-être en assassinant le roi en place
ou en profitant du fait qu'ils aient
tous été tués par des vikings on ne sait
pas c'est une sorte de vercingétorix
écossais sauf que dans cette version il
gagna la prévière quand tu spoil il est
le premier à parvenir à unifier tous les
peuples et à régner sur tous ses
successeurs continue de régner sur ce
qu'on appelle pictes landes jusqu'à une
période de transition entre 1878 et 889
pour le terme de kits splendide
disparaît totalement au profit de
scotland l'ecosse devient un noyau
christianisé et gaélique la disparition
des pictes ne résulterait donc pas du
massacre par un autre peuple mais plutôt
d'un phénomène de transformation
culturelle qui rendrait obsolète le
langage des pierres taillées et les
tatouages
c'est ainsi que kenneth mcalpine est
considéré dans le mythe écossais comme
le premier roi décosse mais ça c'est une
autre histoire
j'espère que cet épisode vous a plu fils
a été un peu dur à écrire parce que déjà
j'ai du mal à m'y mettre
et aussi parce qu'il existe assez peu
d'informations sur les pics donc ces
informations se contredisent parfois
j'ai été assez fasciné par ce peuple à
travers les différents films que j'ai
vus notamment l'ouverture et donc j'ai
voulu en savoir un peu plus ce seuil et
comprendre qu'ils étaient vraiment au
delà des représentations parfois un peu
bizarre qu'on en a aussi mais on se
retrouvera bientôt pour un nouvel
épisode en répondant vous pouvez
toujours me suggérer des thèmes dans les
commentaires je prends tout en note
presque tous rendez vous le mois
prochain probablement à la prochaine